what you'll find is a diagram that
greets you and the first thing I want
you to do I've said this before I
realize it because it deserves to be REM
precise is I want you to redraw that
diagram because when they give you a
diagram to try to help you out but that
diagram is not a substitute for the
process your brain must go through in
constructing your own diagram you draw
it yourself you understand the thing
better wonderful so hopefully you're
getting along the way there I have not
completed my diagram but that's because
there are some things I want to point
out as I construct it that might be
helpful to you here's the bare bones of
it you're given a function they tell you
what the equation of that function is so
I've hoped unto my diagram because seems
like an appropriate and sensible place
to put it and the question you might
notice is quite wordy now you may need
to think back think back a couple of
weeks when you see maybe even sorry take
that back maybe even to the end of last
year when you see a question it's quite
wordy right your ears should sort of
pick up well you your eyes should prick
I don't know what your eyes do right
line up you should pay attention okay
because the words almost certainly I
tried to tell you there's something
special about this question
mathematicians love to steer away from
using words because we can generally
find more concise ways to say things
with with symbols and with diagrams so
we're using words because there's
something that we almost cannot say any
other way so read the question with me
it says find the area of the region
bounded by and then there's that the
x-axis which I've already drawn should
label it and then they give you two
lines x equals 1/2 and x equals 2
they're the bits I haven't put on here
yet ok now I wonder whose brain is
taking over and knows why this question
is not simply given to you as a find
evaluate and then there's some symbols
with an integral
why have they gone to all these words
Russell so it says find the area it's a
curvy thing we're clearly going to use
an integral so why haven't they just
said evaluate and here's an integral
why haven't they just done that what as
Russell's identified
what is it about fighting this area that
demands a little more anyone Michael
okay very good this area that they've
shaded already and I'm about to shade
now in blue this area down here
will render a negative integral right
when you integrate that theme because
it's beneath the axis it will be
negative okay so if they said just
integrate from here to here you're
actually going to get the signed area
not the area area yes
so this thing which I've just shaded in
blue this is why I waited to draw it I'm
going to have to treat differently to
this other area which I'm going to shade
in orange okay so I think they even give
you this corner is that one it's at the
one on the day yes okay so I'm gonna
have to work out each of these
separately as two different integrals
okay so now we've done our thinking now
we can have a go at this the area will
equal one integral at a time I'm even
going to use the same colors I had
before here's the orange one it's signed
area is positive so we can just do it
from one value you rescue to another I
think that's one isn't it that's one we
can just go from one boundary to the
next without any fancy stuff so I'm
gonna go from half to one what am i
integrating what is this function there
it is over there yeah you happy with
that so that area in orange sorry that
integral in orange corresponds to that
area in orange now we do the negative
one now because it's negative rather
than adding integral to integral this
next one I'm actually going to subtract
does that make sense because when I get
this integral it will be negative double
negative cancels out you with me what is
the interval I'm gonna form
where do I start I start from one I get
it - yeah new boundaries but same
function whoops that's an X that's
really messy sorry
same function same integrand it's done
do you see now why they didn't just say
here's integral off you go half of this
question arguably the harder half is to
actually state the interval to
articulate it yourself okay now the
question is somewhat diamond we just
have to do the integration evaluate can
you help me do that
what will be now that were in this topic
what will be the primitive log X
takeaway X and then you've got some
boundaries and you can evaluate those
right subtract it's the same integrand
so you're going to end up with the same
primitive log X - different boundaries
okay now just watch out see that minus
sign there it's gonna be something we
have to watch out for because when I
evaluate each of these and then actually
going to revert to my colors for a
second I should have done it here as
well I'm gonna have like four objects
this takeaway this and then this
takeaway this but this minus sign
applies to everything over here and
that's an easy thing to miss when you're
going through very quickly right so
let's do it one step at a time
upper boundary log one takeaway one yep
there's the upper boundary takeaway log
half bless you minus 1/2 how's that look
all right now I do the next bit this is
coming from here following along - to
keep it all as one object I'm going to
draw a big bracket here so that I know
everything I'm about to do has this
minus sign applied to it is that okay do
you need to do this of course you don't
but it's a it's an error-correcting
measure that I know I'm bad at
forgetting to fix that negative later on
so this just helps me to remember what
are we gonna get here log 2 take away 2
minus log 1 take away
one house that are you happy with that
okay at this point let me just hit pause
I reckon you guys could take care of
this remember you've got lots of logs
flying around you have log laws too
so what you end up with down the bottom
may look different to the person's next
to you if you use different log laws to
simplify
I'd only try and work out what you think
between you guys what would be the the
most simple final way to actually stay
at your answer
don't forget by the way what was the
original question was the original
question to evaluate integral it was to
find the area so therefore eventually I
will have to say these are units squared
I'll give you a 30 to 60 seconds to have
a go if you think you have a final
answer call me over I just want you to
have a look at what I've done on the
next line I'm not finished yet either
because I want to talk about how to get
to the end what have I done
two main things I'm trying to do this
not all at once because I feel like if I
do it all at once there's like four or
five different operations that I've had
to keep in my mind and it's just an easy
way to make a silly mistake right it's
just like if you see someone teaches
right we like to carry lots of things to
and from class and if you ever see a
teacher and they're holding like Amelia
like they're holding them you know iPad
and then text books and then camera and
then try it and then they like trying to
open a door they're just asking to make
a mistake and drop something on the
ground and in the same way if you're
doing four or five simplifications at
the same time you're kind of asking to
it like where do you see the mistakes
come from it's not the only place but
this is a big one okay so I've evaluated
the log ones here in here which are zero
I hope you guys got to that part I also
resolved this extra set of brackets
there so that's a minus that's a plus so
far so good now you'll notice I have
this little hole here I haven't quite
filled this in I said before that we
have lots of different log laws so we
could go through a few different parts
to get to here there's a particular log
law that I think you'll notice makes it
all collapse quite easily and it depends
on this term here this doesn't have to
be the only way you do it but it is
quite error and if you try other ways
I'm going to try and write this log not
as a fraction right but as a log of a
whole number
what log wall can I use to take
advantage of this
say again you need a ladder okay so
interesting that one wing wasn't the one
I was going but I'm gonna write it
anyway because it's true log of 1/2 is
log one takeaway log - isn't it like
it's the the division turns into
subtraction but you already know what
log one is which is zero you saw that so
what you end up with here is negative
log twos that okay
there's another way that might be
slightly more direct to get there can
anyone see it
yeah yeah I can rewrite this half as two
to the negative one and so the negative
one is a power can come out the front
you end up in the same spot so I'm happy
with both okay now the reason why I
hired this is because now have a look
when I start to collect like terms this
is a positive two is that okay you see
where the double negative cancels that's
a positive 2 minus one minus one so all
those things I just highlighted in green
they're all gone they all cancel okay
there are other things that cancel -
this is log 2 positive log 2 you see
that it's that okay this is - low - log
2 minus log 2 these guys which I've
highlighted in slightly different green
also cancel out what's left
I think if I've counted right the only
thing remaining is this term a huh and
of course as we pointed out it's an area
so it's half of a unit squared are you
happy with that